first we've got some breaking news from
Florida so you know it's been hit by
another hurricane overnight Nicole is
her name she made landfall on the
Atlantic coast near Vero Beach very
early this morning it later weakened to
a tropical storm now Florida as you know
is still recovering from Hurricane Ian
that was a category 4 storm that caused
major damage there back in September
Nicole is expected to cut across the
state then turn north and move up the
Eastern Seaboard to us Elise Preston is
in Cape Canaveral Florida near the
Kennedy Space Center Elise good morning
to you still seems a little windy there
it is extremely windy good morning to
you Gail now there were three counties
that underwent mandatory evacuations 45
counties declared states of emergency
and some areas could see storms surge up
to five feet putting buildings along the
coast in danger of collapsing
packing 75 mile per hour winds
dangerous storm surge
and flash flooding it was like Niagara
Falls it was crazy just what a poor and
important in pouring in the coolest
landfall hit Eastern Florida hard
even before it made landfall
Florida's eroding Coastline took yet
another battering
with some homes falling into the ocean
as the storm's outer bands produce
choppy surf there's definitely more
surge than we normally see we met Teddy
Miller outside his home in Martin County
about two hours yesterday where
voluntary evacuations were underway
Wednesday unfortunately being that we
just went through this like four weeks
ago three or four weeks ago it's we're
kind of somewhat prepared Florida is
still recovering just weeks removed from
Hurricane Ian's landfall that storm cut
a path of catastrophic destruction
across the state and officials estimate
the hurricane generated 47 billion
dollars in ensured losses
just like he did with hurricane Ian
Miller's planning to ride out this storm
we'll lose power but
we're pretty set up here it's not a big
deal
now Florida has only battled two other
hurricanes making landfall in November
since record keeping began in 1853 and
you'll remember NASA's Artemis won
rocket that launch was delayed due to
Ian well it's been delayed again it was
supposed to blast off Monday that Target
is now pushed back two days to November
16th but Vlad this is what I can't get
over the rocket has been on the launch
pad this entire storm
wow Elise Preston thank you very much
stay safe